estelle bonjour alors la manifestation a
débuté est-ce que autour de vous il ya
beaucoup de monde comme nous le disait
thomas bonnet à l'instant où il
exactement olivier il prend à plusieurs
amis il y ait un peu de la république
des mallettes et en a qui ont répondu à
l'appel du comité adama traoré garde
nouvel appel à manifester a donc pas de
la part du comité inquiets et servian à
capitaliser sur la précédente
mobilisation du 2 juin dernier une
mobilisation qui avait réuni plus de
20000 personnes dans la capitale selon
as les chiffres de la préfecture de
police
elle s'est manifestement eh bien ils
entendent une nouvelle fois en dénoncer
le racisme et les violences policières
au sein des forces de l'ordre
je vous propose dans l'écouté
quelques-uns en attend surtout des
réponses des actes il faut repenser le
système parce que c'est la violence qui
est systémique pas uniquement du côté
des violences policières mais d'une
manière générale et à tour
discrimination et ya trop d'inégalité et
donc il faut repenser vraiment le
système compact sur un même pied
d'égalité
c'est important de le soutenir ce combat
contre le racisme moi aussi c'est combat
principal et
je pense que c'est notre devoir en tant
que français des chercheurs après tout
ce que ce qui a pu se passer en cette
journée d'été parce qu'il a pour nous
parce que c'est un soutien auprès de la
famille mes proches pour tient peut être
au tour tel que la dame a des yeux qui
ne sont pas aujourd'hui
en tout cas c'est le aussi pour
manifester contre les violences qu'on
qu'ils subirent à longueur de temps sur
il est aussi populaire donc c'est
important pour nous de notre voie de
porter la parole de nous faire écouter
et communiquer notre 80 par rapport à
certaines prestations
je pense que là il se passe quelque
chose en france
de d'historique avec la manifestation de
une semaine mardi dernier à porte de
clichy et celle ici aujourd'hui
et moi je suis là en soutien à toutes
les personnes qui vivent ces
discriminations que moi je ne vis pas et
je vois qu'il ya différents traitements
qui sont réservés comment gens de
couleur etc
ce soit dans les dents dans les
quartiers populaires ou lors des
manifestations et voilà ça n'en sujet je
suis là en soutien